hey everyone I'm Liana Gil Eric coming
at you live from ETS comic-con suite
with the cast of legacies hi guys thank
you so much for coming happy first San
Diego comic-con but given how we ended
season one I feel like this is necessary
so legacies cast this is Danielle
she plays hope forgotten slips but know
what an incredible first season it was
so great to see the evolution of all of
your characters as we approach season
two what and you tell me we I think we
start off after the summer summers
coming to an end in the new school year
is beginning Alaric has not been shaving
all summer
I know it's interesting you know
everybody's forgotten about and so it's
just kind of starting off with where
everybody is and how we all interact
differently now that she's not there and
then we also catch up with her but I
really think that the more interesting
dynamics are gonna be her I'm just
feeling badly for Landon because when we
last checked in with him he was in his
wolf form and with hope being gone are
you stuck definitely yeah
I'm just in a weird place right now like
between my my human psyche a more wolf's
psyche I don't know who I am so we don't
know what's gonna happen when I
back if I want to be I want to still be
the alpha or but I still have feelings
for hope or will I want to be around my
brother in the dynamic between me and
Jay so I just somebody crazy whenever I
I do come out of wolf or going on to my
next question which was for Landon but
we just thought that sweet I love you
scene for the second time uh between
hope and Landon and then your girlfriend
you kind of forgot about her not your
fault what what can you tease about his
evolution in season two now that he
actually knows he has a place at the
Salvatore Academy yeah so I mean he
obviously when you remove something as
big as that it affects things as big as
it seems like a good but then the idea
of putting it back is the interesting
part but you don't necessarily know what
putting it back just means going back to
normal or if how the shock waves ripple
effects how the ripple effects is gonna
affect everything and how it's gonna
affect yeah we may not be remembering
hope but I am remembering the mg kinda
has a little bit of a crush still how's
he doing in that romance department I
mean it's not hold on I think they're
setting me up to be you that's what I
anytime he likes somebody just don't
quite seem to work out you know I mean
Easton ended vaguely positive with the
but I mean things ended vaguely positive
with with Nia Jenny what can you tease
is coming up for Lizzy she had quite an
emotional journey last year trying to
master her magical outbursts yes
that's gonna keep evolving we're gonna
keep addressing this sort of
but Lindsay is actually living her best
life now that hope is not around and
she's having a semester yes fans love
Josie and Penelope's dynamics so much
I've never seen a shift of catch on so
quickly what has it been like for you
having that fan reaction and it's been
really interesting to watch just because
I mean I can watch a show in passing and
think oh yeah I [ __ ] Klaus and Caroline
it's like a prime example but I had
never felt so deeply the way that the
fans feel about Posey and so it's like
so cool to watch because they care so
much and to the latter part of that
question you can't answer
Candace King is going to be moderating
your panel I'm so excited
please tell me that means that we're
getting Caroline
because I so badly want to see her
dynamic with the two of you what has it
been like for you to vote to find that
offspring connection with Candace oh
it's been great yeah she met with me and
Kaylee before we even started and gave
us a bunch of advice she did sweet
things because we had never been to
Atlanta before and she like told us
where to live and like basically mother
this and to get the first season we
asked her about like fan interactions
and all kinds of unexpected episode was
one of my personal favorites of season
one you guys are all way too talented so
way to go um is that something that
could be more of like a yearly situation
which you guys want to show off your
singing and dancing skills a little bit
more I think we all loved doing the
talent show I think that's up to the
writers I think that they always have
some plan in their back pocket Musa came
to sit down I also love the fact that we
had the miss Mystic Falls pageant which
was such a fun callback to all of our
Mystic Falls days of The Vampire Diaries
are there any other traditional Mystic
Falls events Founders Day that I just
don't know how I'm allowed to talk about
it you know what I'm getting in trouble
so I'm gonna say that's one up to the
writers we're definitely keeping with in
Mystic Falls this season you might even
see more
maybe the Mystic Falls High School and
we're going to keep in that world
question for our non-human characters
sorry and you have to play your werewolf
abilities on spleen or your which
abilities or your vampire abilities who
has the toughest time channeling that
onset not in terms of like who has the
toughest time but like is it hard off
your witching skills is it like to be
able to bring that to life so like one
of the first things that I ever shot
after I flew in was my world wolf
transformation and I just I tell the
story all the time like I was I didn't
know what I was doing I wasn't really
familiar with the entire world so I kind
of just went for it I had this like
prosthetic back on and then I just
remember hope looking down at me while I
was on the ground and I just started
like I was like rolling around screaming
my arms were great here and then they
could and she was like you know the
camera this is so physically taxing
though you know I mean like like for for
my vamp stuff I I get all huffy and
puffy and whatnot in a lot of emotion
but why do I like after you know chess
where he be huffing and puffing but I
feel like when you're having to compel
you're like seeing into someone's soul
so for all of my spells to know what
they mean I'll like translate them and
then kind of loosely see the ASL sign
for it and then like create a variant
variation on that so
oh well lastly guys what are you keeping
your fingers crossed that you could see
for your characters in season - what's
on your legacies bucket list
that's like bucket list for the entire
and see how that affects the entire
thank you all so much for sitting down
with me and I hope you have an amazing
panel amazing Comic Con thank you all so
much for watching we'll see you next
time
[Music]